we have had a trend of the woke feminist
infiltrating the media this has happened
for like a hundred years
however we have seen feminism really
going crazy in Disney right now so
recently Disney cast
a snow white who hates Snow White let's
show the clip you said you were bringing
a Modern Edge to it on Sage what do you
mean by that I just mean that it's no
longer 1937 and we absolutely wrote a
snow white that is not going to be saved
by the prince she's not gonna be saved
by The Prince and she's not gonna be
dreaming about true love she's dreaming
about becoming the leader she knows she
can be and the leader that her late
father told her that she could be if she
was Fearless Fair Brave and true and so
it's just a really incredible story for
I think young people everywhere to see
themselves in novite is running for
president
I'm launching my campaign